good morning it's day two
yesterday was so exhausting
who knew maybe all of you guys knew but
i didn't know who knew that being extra
[ __ ] cold drains so much energy from
you um we were freezing i was freezing
that like i woke up today and i was so
sore from just sitting outside next to a
freaking fire
anyway about to train
i've had this allergic to pentecost
um
sweatshirt or a jumper as some of you
guys like to call it in other countries
uh for a few years now and i've never
worn it because i think it was just too
big so today i'm like i really want to
wear this so i cut it i actually folded
it in half and i went snip it came out
perfectly so now
i'm gonna go train
and here we are
we got
the duty set up
we got papa over here stretching some
call it special
some call it love
oh let's see let's see
let's see which one he's doing
he is love making for sure this is
exactly what it looks like yep
yep
damn look at that arch
cat camel [ __ ] better watch out it's
about to be the bart bart
and we got tyke over here
set up
with his own little heater because it
gets pretty chilly in here
and he is just glued
and he's eating
a coffee cake in the morning
yeah it's a cinnamon cake
all right so we're about to get it on
get our sweat home feel really good
if i could recommend and i highly
recommend for you guys is
as soon as you wake up get some water in
your system and just move for at least
30 minutes i promise you
i mean and move to break a sweat i
promise you
after those 30 minutes you're going to
feel so accomplished and i'm only saying
30 minutes 30 minutes is too much i say
10 minutes after 10 minutes of some good
sweat you're going to be like
let's start the day it's kind of like
meditative for a little bit you know
what i mean
so
i'm about to get my meditation on
check in with you guys in a little bit
how's training coming about bikini
how's training coming along
good um i just realized i'm doing 90
pounds today i don't know if that's
i've gone on a bench since
a few years oh i got dizzy since before
the
bubulations and then the monkey cheeto
yeah
yeah i think my top was like maybe 123
or something yeah one bench but today
it's for reps right yeah and then i got
the boobs
back in 2015 and that's it i never
really benched again
i'm so tired you look exhausted yeah i
don't know what happened we went
shooting
as you guys saw and then today i woke up
feeling
really off
and um i'm like i can't be getting sick
because this guy was sick maybe two
weeks ago okay where you going
[Music]
to go pee little baby
that's so cute i can't believe he's
peeing by himself where are baby girls i
know let's kill me
go pee little baby i'd rather him pee
than change a diaper that's for sure
yeah um
that you went shooting yesterday it
might be a little bit weird i don't know
why i don't know if it's like adrenaline
or like because it was so cold my body
was just really crazy
yeah and windy
so yeah right now
i'm actually having a pretty decent
training session which is funny because
i'm probably i feel like i'm dying so i
think i'm really focused like don't kill
yourself under the bar
um i'm proud of you for pushing through
it
thank you it was all with the help of
our barbell brigade pre-workout not even
trying to do a cheap plug i'm really not
trying to
it just i really needed
a kick in the teeth and our pre-workout
really does that yeah so
yeah without it i don't know i i think
i wouldn't have finished i don't think i
would have finished so
thank you but also what's dope is
for progress to be made all you gotta do
is show up
true so you didn't feel good still
showed up today and i'm that i'm proud
of you thank you because many other days
especially on the holidays it's easy to
just quit and get cross side you know
well i shouldn't have done that thank
you
all right monkey
whoa what's going on what's going on
all right so training is done but we are
back
with the windy outsides there's
it's projected to be 50 mile per hour
winds tonight
i'm not gonna be able to sleep i'm not
used to this this is
craziness
okay well other than that duty
what are you doing
okay brp i got a baby pulling my jacket
off hold on
duty
so for christmas i got tyka something
that i kind of slightly regret buying
him why do you regret it what do you
know what do you know
i think you're gonna go from that thing
yeah yeah but why do you regret it
because it's creepy what's creepy about
it let me show you okay so i like
getting taika a mix of like just dumb
toys and
um smart toys
so just like super thoughtless like
throw [ __ ] around race cars like those
type of toys where it's like just dumb
toys right
and then i'd like to get them the
educational ones
like an egg that grows a dinosaur in it
for example
so this has been in the water wait let
me show you
this has been in the water now
for about a day and a half almost two
days and it's supposed to hatch and it's
gonna hatch a dinosaur okay
but this thing grosses me
the hell out oh come on there it is oh
god that's a real live dinosaur in there
and taco's been so excited because
takes a couple days to hatch so what i
like about it is it teaches type of
patients because every like couple hours
they'll come and check and you'll see
one little crack you'll see another
little crack so i think it's cool that
it's not one of those toys that's like
immediate satisfaction you know wow
dude
you just schooled me hella hard but i
did call it educational yeah so this is
educational i didn't think of patience
though i just wanted him to see the
process of something hatching yeah
because how many toys are is it like you
open it and you can play
you know all of them yeah exactly and
that's why i like lego so much because
you open it and it's useless you have to
build it piece by piece that's probably
why i didn't like it
i never liked legos i know you're too
impulsive you don't have black patients
well i don't think it's impulsive
discipline you you're just unreliable
there's a lot of things like that
the [ __ ]
excuse you sir
honestly i just thought it's because i
liked creativity
that is creative but it's creative
you get a lego set that's supposed to be
like astronauts you first follow the
instructions and you build the rocket
ship right after you're done you take it
all apart and you rebuild something a
cape
okay
okay so
men really hate to listen
proof
i said i thought it was because i lack
creativity which is very true
that's all i said well you thought
correct yeah yeah i know okay hey how
come you look kind of jacked in that
sweater
because i listen with my muscles
oh look at that you miss having a dog so
much hot cutie you bite you
i'm the dog and tyka's the pup
but why are you making dog food baby it
looks funny but it actually tastes bomb
okay you're not wrong it actually tastes
really bomb shout outs to stan efforting
for creating this monster mash and no
we pay for it he doesn't hook us up it's
really that good it's really good and
look this is how good it is
um
it has our fridge right there it's
stocked up with it all the time big fan
and it's almost like cold stones yep and
it's healthy it's uh this one i think
it's bison with a
bone broth so you get all kinds of good
like amino acids and all that
micronutrients
and you have veggies like spinach bell
pepper and then put in some white rice
give it to taiko and me both going to be
nice and healthy boys
yeah i'm actually not hungry
like um i was mentioning while i was
training i feel funny still and i i
don't feel sick like her cough sick
but i just feel off
i don't even know how to explain it
just
off so yeah because of that i don't feel
like eating it like i have no appetite i
had lunch
and then that i was like forcing myself
to eat it because it just i felt like i
was about to like
like two more bites and i'm gonna throw
it all up so i'm like oh i'm just gonna
chill cause this is not making me feel
good what you oon about i'm so nervous
well i saw an old apple pie in there i'm
gonna eat that after
how can we talk to your food
there's no one in the there's literally
no one in the kitchen this is what it
was and you're like ooh
i know but you say it out loud most
people have that in their head i don't
know sometimes things come out
sometimes things come in stay inside
okay fine
okay so taika and papa have been
having the most beautiful bond i mean
they've always had a really beautiful
bond but now it's even cooler and more
beautiful than ever before
and they have this thing that they do to
get it
okay show me
no you you look normal you look this way
okay
no you and papa do it i don't know how
to do it the right way i look this way
yeah this is what when we look this way
okay you go with papa first and now go
second let's go together there's no way
duty
okay try it
no
but you didn't look at papa
okay well look at this you and papa do
it we both like this okay
together
[Music]
[Music]
you're so proud
okay so i was never involved in the mix
of like looking he just did that right
now that sounds like so confused how's
that gonna happen but it's
always them too what
watch tiger can do this don't do it yet
don't try it don't do it watch like this
you just watch this watch
watch look look look careful can do this
watch
what is that a pirate
no it's
it's a pirate i'm a pirate
look at that
nope
because it's 8 30 and ty is in bed
already i know he's usually in bed by
like um like he's past nine
but he didn't have a nap today
so he was so tired and it just felt like
it was already like time for him to
sleep like nine times for him to sleep
but it's only 8 30.
you know what what i'm gonna party and
that just means i'm going to knock the
[ __ ] out it's like 30. i know
yeah like taika didn't have a nap today
and so i was like oh man should i take
them to jiu jitsu because the minute i
took him into the car it was uh
like 3 30 already in our life
he did we were driving and i start once
it starts getting all smooth
then you see his eyes kind of going like
this and then i'm like oh no because
like sometimes he'll knock out for just
a brief second right before jiu jitsu he
doesn't have a nap and then he has the
grumpiest time at jiu jitsu you know
and then so i was faced with the
thoughts of the father where i'm like
wait when i'm when he's grumpy
that's my own personal discomfort when i
zoom out of it it's actually good that
we're having the schedule and he
understands
whether rain or shine or not or tired or
whatever you got to do what you got to
do and you got to train
and so we took him and he actually had
the best
training session let me show you guys
this so he usually
um is one of the rowdier kids because
you know he's like his papa is a
troublemaker but today he did so good
that he was the model
for
the rest of the classic he did one of
the moves so good that the coach was
like taika show everyone how it's done
check it
[Music]
so you out that he did that like knee
sliding to spinarooski
and he did it so good that he was a
model of the class and he's never the
model of the class so i was like man i'm
so glad i took him because i had all
these reservations you know and it's
usually just your own like insecurity of
like oh no he's gonna be so grumpy he's
gonna cry he's gonna be pain in the ass
and make me look bad
but when you get out of your own head
who knows what's gonna happen i'm so
proud and then so right now we had him
drink his milk like usual his new
favorite movie is venom
and um because it's still part of like
the spider-man series
and he knocked out and like mama said
it's 8 30 so it's time for us to also
not go so we'll see you guys tomorrow
good night